it's time for screen junkies movie bides
[Applause]
movie fights thanks for joining us
everybody what what another exciting
edition of movie fight so we have a
couple of awesome combatants we're gonna
be talking some comic book movies
inspired by Black Panther and all sorts
of fun stuff let's meet our brave
competitors first he is from the
podcasts only stupid answers show and
he's a friend of the family welcome to
the show DJ Woolridge yeah we hired an
interior decorator to come in here and
spruce it up yeah so DJ plug the
out of something alright so I do a
podcast called lonely stupid answers you
can find everything you need to know
about that podcast and more on only
stupid answers calm and we just launched
our new merch line including this shirt
so if you dig it go to only super
answers.com for more heck yeah I love
the merch very very much so
and she's also a friend of the family
and sort of the co-hosts of Marvel movie
news welcome back marki McCarty here
tell us some stuff that's going on uh
yeah well yes Marvel movie news so you
can catch me on that I'm also I love
wrestling you catch me on WWE Raw
after-show on afterbuzz TV um you know
what a friend of mine and I in regards
to wrestling we're just talking about
bleeding you're bleeding is yeah will
you cut yourself up so you'll bleed in
the middle of a match or something some
matches need to have a little color yeah
I thought about bleeding during movie
fights so I just like start bleeding
profusely during the face I'm comment
below if you guys want to see me blade
during movie fights there's a number of
videos coming out about a black panther
yeah yeah I got to interview the cast I
got to be in the same room as Angela
Bassett oh yes she wore my panther
blaster it's the same rumors like that
cast is ridiculous Angela Bassett Forest
Whitaker Lupita Nyong'o and just you
know that's not even mentioning chadwick
boseman which I just mentioned um
archaea thank you so much yeah I know I
love this I mean I your your set and
everything reminds me of what is it
legend of the Hidden Temple hell yeah
so for those of you rejoining us again
for the first time if that makes any
sense
the show works thusly we have three
judges myself and the dance Dan Moreau
what is going on the man holding down
the fact-check the Olmec yes that's a
nice deep cut yeah thank you
you know what else is a deep cut what's
that bleeding on my forehead if I play
the princess
can you please I'm the friend you talk
to and I need you to not blame because I
want your forehead to stay that way
forever thank you you know what a little
Botox will fix everything
oh no that's frightening
Daniel Radford so just in short I'm
gonna I'm gonna pick a winner of the
argument Dan's gonna pick a winner in
the argument and then if we're tied we
go to the woman holding it down on the
socials Daniel Radford tell us a little
bit more about where you're doing over
there when you guys vote and you have to
vote on YouTube not Twitter YouTube when
you put in your votes I'm going to be
tallying them and if we go through a tie
I will that'll be the deciding vote if
you don't see the poll what you're gonna
want to do is go up to this side right
down hit that AI card and then the polls
will come down if you don't see the eye
card then you go down below hit the gear
turn annotations on and off the our card
should appear those weren't worth the I
card should appear the iCarly should
appear tacos will be fantastic because
the AI card will appear and then you can
vote there Thank You babies and also I'm
gonna be reading your comments so please
I'm at me daddy how likes his dank memes
yes yes I do
and yes send us some dank memes send us
some stupidity and you know what I was
thinking
tell me if this is like the worst idea
in the world Danielle like if you get
like a ridiculous meme just turning it
around and holding it up to the camera
but with the computer I've seen what
people write doing the show that's a
terrible got nice ones I was just about
to say we live in the future until that
comment no one said that I have nice one
[Laughter]
Thank You Danielle thank you for waiting
through all the nonsense and hold the
balance a stick I like it yes
and we like you so here's how the fight
works once again there are three regular
questions that they will debate it and
fight it out on at the end of those
three rounds we go to a four question
speed round so it can be three zip but
the other competitor can come back if
they sweep that speed round it's
anybody's game sounds like fun DJ yes
you feelin it you want to start this
thing up okay yeah we can do it how
ready are you mark eeeh I'm ready this
is this is fun this is like this is what
I do like everyday let's just do them JC
you drop that sickest package
[Music]
jte best package in the biz Billy we saw
you pass in front of the camera by the
way all right here is the first question
of today's movie fights in honor of
Black Panthers opening weekend what's
the best comic book origin movie in
honor of Black Panthers opening weekend
what is the best comic book origin movie
djay we start with you it's almost not
even fair because spider-man easily has
the best origin in all of comic books
period not only does he have the
personal tragedy that they all need but
it's also personally connected to him
and decisions he made it's not something
that just happened to them and also it
has the wish fulfillment that we all
want and our superhero comics about a
young person discovering the power they
have inside themselves and now you take
that and you perfectly translate it to
Sam Raimi's first spider-man film and
that is easily the best superhero origin
movie we've ever gotten it was so good
that unfortunately it led and almost
every Marvel movie to be an origin movie
out of the gate almost every superhero
movie is an original movie because this
origin movie was so good so tight
captured everything that people loved
about the character and brought it
through the big screen for the first
time spider-man Sam Raimi got it Thank
You DJ marquee ax okay blade is actually
the best comic book origin movie for a
multitude of reasons one of which
without blade happening in 1998 you
don't have iron man you don't have
spider-man in 2002 a blade is actually
the origin the superhero origin story
that started everything off and with
blade with being comical origins it was
originally by Marv Wolfman and it what
blade does is that it transcends the
comic books like it has the comic book
origins a blade he is a vampire fighter
he is a daywalker he is trying to do his
best he has personal tragedy and then
along with that it skips ahead it has
blade where he's already been bitten by
Morbius so then that's how he's the
daywalker already and then along with
that it hit so hard it changed
superhero movies before blade you had
Howard the Duck you had bat nipples you
had all of that once blades grittiness
comic book origin a Vampire Killer
goodness happened then you got the MCU
alright fight it out you guys listen
blade play this round I'm gonna be
honest it's been a minute since I've
seen it but blade is rad however is
amazing I think I think it's hard to
argue that it's technically an origin
movie like we get the origin at the
beginning but like you said we skip over
all the stuff we don't see where he
meets Whistler we don't see how he gets
us late we don't see them like learn to
be blade like you could easily do a
blade begins on this thing comic book
origin movies like as it is like the
literal thing with it is like where
you're getting them as when they're a
superhero like with this we're getting
blade exactly where we need him to be
which is why with things like Spider Man
homecoming we didn't have to go through
the bite and check the boxes check the
box that you know we got it where we
needed it to be yeah but you wouldn't
argue that spider-man homecoming is an
origin movie where Sam Raimi you would
argue that that is spider-man's origin
it's you show where you get the bite you
show his decision to make money off of
his superpowers which everybody which is
what part of what makes him so relatable
you see the death of Uncle Ben you see
the decision like that that is by the
textbook definition of origin but then
also when we're saying best comic book
origin movie I mean kind of when you
compare blade to Spider Man like Spider
Man is a little bit more of a let's say
a patient snoozer
as opposed to what late would be let me
let me get those those synapse firing
for you okay so with blade you have
traci lords and blade and she is leading
meat humans into an underground like
blood bath rave room and this is how
blade starts you meet blade when he's
got like this chakra like thing and and
like he's got this uh he's got like all
these weapons like garlic and silver and
he's tearing but through all of the
vampires and this is essence of blade
this is everything that blade is and you
get that within the first 10 minutes of
the movie you know you meet Peter Parker
in spider-man is as Peter Parker as an
ER being beaten up being picked on so
you can connect with him so you can
relate to him so you fall
him through his journey to becoming
spider-man so that's meaningful to you
as an audience member and I will be
completely honest like when I see Wesley
Snipes and blade and he's just
completely age-appropriate and awesome
and cool for everything what blade is
and then I see Tobey Maguire and he was
like 27 years old when he was playing
Peter Parker with that and it's just
it's a total and miss it was too much
like Tom Holland that is a Peter fifteen
year old it's not just about appearance
as a young kid as many young kids
watching that movie we could completely
relate with that experience most high
school movies are I mean a Tom Hollands
like 20-something so that's not that is
not completely unusual if the idea is
the journey that you go on to get there
not only that blade barely hat I'll give
you it's a good thing that they it's a
good thing that they skipped over it
because plates origins boring just like
they should kiss skip or dr. strange
because dr. strangers origin is boring
spider-man's origin a squeeze is as
iconic and important as Batman's and as
Superman's and it's defining to the
superhero genre and and it's not only
again it's not only that idea part of
what makes characters like Superman and
Captain American all these other
characters so iconic is that wish with
them and of seeing somebody like you
become something better spider-man
caused himself by being selfish I
understand what you just said is exactly
what blade is as being a black superhero
movie and being that back in 1998 that
is one of the reasons that makes it a
best comic book origin movie because
black superheroes they had to fill the
cracks and be underneath others and
that's what you run into with Black
Panther that is what you run into with
blade that's when you run into with Sam
Wilson and and everything like that and
for this to be a movie that happened
back then and it exploded the MCU
because of it it exploded DC because of
it that is what a best common origin
movie I have a couple quick questions up
for you guys one what is the difference
between an origin movie and a first
movie in a series and how does your
movie fit as either one an origin movie
is a is a
movie that shows the origin of a
character how they became the hero that
they are so spider-man is literally that
we start with Peter Parker normal high
school are getting beaten up we see him
getting bitten by a science experiment
gone wrong becoming spider-man learning
to use those powers making mistakes with
those powers which again is part of what
makes his origins so important because
it's not just the tragedy that happened
to him it's mistakes he made that caused
them which as part as part of what made
this character so relatable and then see
him become the hero that we will know
and follow and kicked off an entire
franchise okay an origin movie is when
you have because comic books are a mess
they're huge and they span for decades
an origin movie is when you take the
essence of that character and you are
able to put it together in a digestible
package for mainstream so that is why
blade is that way because what they did
they had to distill down I mean that
started in the in the 70s I was like 76
and the movie actually went up in 98
that is it that's a lot to have to
distill down so they took the essence of
blade and they gave us that in that
comic movie they gave us that iconic
figure and it hit so hard we got three
movies out of that and we got all of
this afterward and we're still getting
blade movies today actually actually
since it has reverted back to Marvel and
it did that in 2011 it is a very real
possibility that we could have blade and
a property coming up blade will show up
on agents of shield at best show well
not agents of shield in the in the
actual you know think itself but like
with the comic books in fact they
replaced his hand with with agents of
shield hands okay I'm gonna throw you
guys another question I want each of you
to talk to me about the moments of
seeing your character your titular
character I love that word by the way
seeing them in their suits using their
powers for the first time because that's
something I really associate with an
origin story I want to hear how that
affected you and excited you and got you
jazzed up about that character mark yeah
let's start with you okay um right well
when you saw blade like and I and I
already describes with everything like
when it hits off right away in that rave
room and when he's just like tearing
through vampires the thing that actually
did it for me
is that there there is a particular
scene and it's it's later on it's a it's
when okay so it's when there's all of
these human skins that are behind glass
in this and a vampire bolt and you have
blade walking through that and he's
going through like a really tough time
with things and he actually gets
captured by the vampires and with that
there he he's he's laying there like
against the pillar they've stabbed they
they've stabbed a silver spike into his
shoulder and and in that moment he
starts laughing he starts laughing at
them he starts laughing at the
circumstance because he is mother-loving
blade and he will always be blade and
then no one is gonna tear him down no
one is gonna take him down and he and he
laughs at them and he goes and guess
what I didn't come alone and then you
have Whistler
bust through that wall and he takes them
all out that having that and all the
vampires were white having that really
says something to you
he is the daywalker he is tragedy in
motion
he's blade thank you DJ uh getting her
the costume is really cool but
everything before that really
establishes who Peter is and why why you
should care about him as a character
seeing seeing his his loner existence
seeing him being picked on which no
matter who you are no matter what walk
of life you had you come from you can
relate to that but then once he gets the
abilities and seeing him learn them for
the first time seeing him try the webs
and try and figure out how to make it
work seeing seeing him its crawl up the
wall for the first time all that stuff
building up to when he does finally put
on the costume and he's he's taking
people down and everything it was a
moment where you realize that that wow
we can do this this is the thing I'm
seeing everything I loved about the
comics brought to the big screen and
blade opened up the door to say hey
this is a thing x-men was like yeah this
could be a thing spider-man is like no
this is happening spider-man was a
moment spider-man is the floodgates the
the x-men and blade knocked on the door
spider-man's the one who opened it and
opened the floodgates because it was so
it was the first time that we really
captured a character the people loved
and the way they knew him from the
comics and not just not a mainstream big
character somebody people have been
waiting for and so that moment when he's
in costume taking down bad guys because
there's the montage where he's just
taking people and everybody's talking
about how excited they are for
spider-man is the audience member you're
super excited to not just because it's a
character you know not just because the
costume was cool but because you saw him
as a person that you could relate to and
step by step as he discovers this new
side to himself time
wow you guys what a collision the blade
versus the spider just to save obvious
things associated with them um yeah a
great battle and marquee ax you brought
up a ton of important stuff about this
character and your passion behind
talking about this character and like as
you were describing that scene where he
got stabbed in the shoulder with a spike
like I was like feeling feelings like
like going back there and thinking about
that but I feel like you were fighting
an like a dual argument of origin story
and importance to comic book movies and
I really think that you sold me on the
importance of blade on the importance on
culture seeing a black superhero like
headline a film for what the first time
and just the power behind it djay right
out of the gate you were talking about
the wish fulfillment behind spider-man
seeing him use his powers and
identifying with finding these new
powers for the first time and just as
far as origin stories go and being true
to the question which is what is the
best comic book origin movie you listed
up that stuff like Uncle Ben and the
other moments the the spider-bite that I
feel caused
true a true origin story seeing those
comic book moments so that being said
great answers in a powerful argument
mark kiya but I got to go with DJ on
this one Dan Merle let's go to you yeah
just quickly breaking down the facts the
two great graphs of the age of Spiderman
actors respectively Tobey Maguire was 27
and the first spider-man and Tom Holland
was 21 and it's becoming so well
researched there
yeah blade was in 98 the next movie
based on a Marvel property was x-men in
the year 2000 the same year that Blade 2
came out in the embassy began in 2008
and the next well the next DC movie
unfortunately was Catwoman but the next
year was Constantine a Batman Begins so
they recovered they were in a little bit
yeah based on the arguments I I think
that DJ sold me better on why spider-man
was the better origin movie I agree with
what you said how about the importance
of blade I thought was really well
stated but DJ sold me better on why
spider-man was the better origin movie
introducing us to the character the
hallmarks of that so I got to go into
dj's alright so that means DJ takes the
point
but Danielle let us know what's going on
on the Internet and overwhelmingly it
went 75 to 24% for digital to DJ
Wooldridge and I had to do was probably
never do it again I don't know I can't
guarantee that but some of the dankest
means i've seen a lot of you are
wondering weiss Iron Man wasn't brought
up has a really good origin story at G
4000 or zero our two forces Iron Man was
a practically unknown character until he
blasted on the scene and 2008 now he is
as recognizable as Mickey Mouse a
perfect introduction thank you all for
the icarly love I have seen all of their
memes with those spaghetti tacos a lot
of people were getting into a debate
about the difference between an origin
story and a first movie
what that might yeah and so that was
very interesting Batman Begins got a lot
of really really good things and at Jack
underscore D underscore Manheim said at
DJ talks trash could be to your
advantage both your opponent Marcia and
social media monitor Danielle are likely
to be distracted by their odd
fascination with Dolph Lundgren's
Punisher that is an odd fascination I've
seen the clip of him fighting the ninjas
I'm like I need to see this movie I need
it in my life I'm sorry I'm sorry I'll
get to it I think we've established we
all need a little more Dolph Lundgren's
Punisher in our life also you know
mentioned but when I was thinking about
guardians I thought guardians was a
strong origin story and a fun ride okay
second question of the day who should
play he-man and Skeletor in the Masters
of the Universe reboot speaking of Dolph
Lundgren what the og he-man the og
Punisher and Frank Langella how's
Skeletor don't sleep on Langella tour my
grandfather took Langella tour to help
with his cholesterol yes who should play
he-man and Skeletor in the Masters of
the Universe reboot I love this question
mark eeeh let's start with you okay I
can only think of one duo that I wanted
to play he-man and Skeletor and that is
Dwayne the rock Johnson and Kevin Hart
this Masters of the Universe film is
going to be so incredibly good with
these two and you can tell just from
what we've had with them in the past
with like Central Intelligence and then
having Jumanji and so you it's very
possible for you to have that can't be
fun along with that seriousness that you
can do because the rock is on that and
then plus the rock is he-man we've all
seen that body and and you know the
Scorpion King we know what he's rocking
he's a you know wrestler can you smell
what The Rock is cooking yes I can he is
cooking that King Adam up for he-man and
then so far with a Kevin Hart being
Skeletor keeping in mind Skeletor
he's like he's a sorcerer so he doesn't
necessarily have to be a really huge
buff guy I know and in the 80s
Funimation he tends to you know be kind
of let's say Abbot astok in a bit tall
but he's also okay like alan oppenheimer
yeah you cannot tell me that kevin hart
wit and smash some Skeletor and plus
skeletor's blue so kevin hart can play
him and I just I really I really want to
see Kevin Hart trying to control Panth
or like right next to him so yep that's
what duo BAM alright DJ who you got
listen he-man is a classic franchise and
so you want to hit that right tone of
being true to it true to what it is well
modernizing it for the modern world and
for he-man specifically you need a
character the not only and probably most
importantly it looks good with a shirt
off which the rock of course has but
also somebody that has that charisma has
that charm somebody that can smirk and
weep their way through the role and like
really selling out and but also because
he is a prince that finds the power of
Grayskull that means the power of
Grayskull has some of that boyish charm
some of that youthful energy so I went
with Channing Tatum because I thought he
had the perfect combination of he looked
badass in the tunic and also he would
have he would have that youthful energy
he could capture that youthful energy
that you'd want from
we talked about wish-fulfillment
spider-man you want to have a little bit
of that with he-man as well and for
Skeletor you know you know it's gonna be
CGI you want or even if it is makeup you
want somebody that can project menace
through all that so I went with Andy
Serkis our premiere our premiere motion
capture performer and also wouldn't you
love to see him get to play the big bad
that he didn't get to play in Star Wars
Wow both of these answers are so good
and so different they're tearing me
apart though you guys but also you know
we're on the verge of being too they're
getting too much oh well the rock has
that Samoan gorgeousness and that beauty
he's looking he's gonna look that same
way I I gave you the Scorpion King and
you gave me the from this is the
end like you realize that and then plus
just saying Masters of the Universe has
had a really hard time like making it
happen starting it up they just lost
Goyer before that they lost mcg Channing
Tatum kept on trying to do gambit for
like 10 11 years we don't need anymore
that bad yeah he's ready for that
opportunity the gaming prompts are have
nothing to do with him the only reason
that movie is even talked about getting
made is because of him
he-man if he did he made her would
happen in a second and also it's it's
important to point out that fanboys hate
it when you mess with their franchises
so if you're gonna make this like a kind
of throwaway comedy with money you could
just burn money if you cast Kevin Hart
[Music]
yes Kevin Hart was the big Kevin Hart
was not the big bad Kevin Burke should
be Orko Kevin Hart should be the little
Headly wizard sidekick cracking jokes
you know what let's make Kevin hurt or
go in my movie bear I'm making all the
money anyway no see the thing of it is
though with this combo it's like the two
of them together have you seen
intelligence have you seen my point is
is that this duo will make it happen
they have the drive behind them to
finally make this happen to keep a
director on this movie so we can make it
happen and then plus we're falling into
that trap that we think that these
movies are for us they're not for us
they're for the future us there for us
to enjoy get along roxeanne you have
Kevin Hart that's good for us but that's
good for them too yeah it's kind of like
what what Pixar does where it's some
movie for kids but it's like we enjoy
that we're not but we are making movies
for the next generation but that's not
where the majority of the tickets all
scream that's not always Star Wars it's
the biggest-selling movie of all time if
you go to people that haven't seen that
movie that's China and didn't go to see
that movie all right so you so you want
you want that fanbase you want the
people that care about it and so you
want them to be invested and so you want
to give them you want it you want to
progress it but you also want to give
them what they pay for and if you're if
you're making he-man you're not making
Jumanji you're not making Central
Intelligence you're making Conan the
Barbarian in space okay I am an than I
did because like masses of universe
that's quasi futile meets like this
futuristic - it's like a sci-fi epic
barbarian in space between these two
between the rock and Kevin Hart we have
that covered we have that futuristic
feudalism covered yes we have you know
the kids
Kosar know what you're gonna have going
to get the movie make this movie this
movie is gonna be released in February
music Mike is not gonna get this movie
me you're gonna have people think that's
you know what I've already seen the rock
in two Fast and Furious movies of this
year I've seen them in I've seen the
rage and it's like you know what you
know what I don't need that in the Cask
ever hurt as Skeletor which is huge miss
casting I've already read 20,000 think
pieces about how it's the worst cast in
the world guess I don't know what I
don't want to see this movie but you
know what Channing
I'm in the trail he's got that boys
charm he's got the energy he looks
badass I'm gonna throw a quick question
at you here I'm gonna name three
characters I want you to tell me who's
gonna play them in your movie to take a
moment and think about it
sure ah beast man and man-at-arms who's
gonna play you're Shira
you're a beast man and man-at-arms okay
okay
yeah teyla was before Shira came on the
scene she got her own movie though okay
I'll let you have your teyla played by
Tila Tequila peace master and whose last
one man-at-arms DJ okay hold on hold on
hold on beastly
that's where that's you know that's the
yeah that's the sticking point we'll get
there we'll figure it out as we go huh
sure
all right so for Shiro slash Tila slash
whoever the female lead is I would say I
would go with Amber Heard I think I
think she's really coming in a moment
she's playing Mira I think she can
capitalize that on a really cool way and
the way they could market this movie and
make this movie I think she'd play
really well off of Channing Tatum I
think they'd have a cool fun community
energy because she was in Pineapple
Express so we know she has the comedy
chops and Channing Tatum likes to play
around with those boys too so they've
got they come from similar comedic
backgrounds and for man-at-arms I would
say Terry Crews cuz you know you're
gonna want it you're gonna want to cast
this movie with the the biggest muscle
is dudes that you can get but again they
can have fun because if you want to say
you know Gardens galaxy makes a lot of
money so if you want to say Bernie's a
galaxy meets Conan the Barbarian you
want some of that that winking comic
energy with your bombastic action with
your bigger larger-than-life characters
and Terry Crews is hilarious and he can
be completely badass and for beastman
I'm gonna go with Dwayne the rock
Johnson and we have Kevin Hart as Orko
okay right no my coattails mark eeeh
okay so for teyla i chose Tessa Thompson
because I'm actually no this is not it's
not a Marvel property so we can go ahead
and have tests on that just from how she
depicted out Valkyrie teyla is complex
she is a complex character she is but
she is all woman and I think that we
could finally explore the bisexuality
that they knew that kind of hey Teela
Teela got it got it
so so we can we can explore that with
that as far as Beastmaster is concerned
I'm gonna go the Winston Duke route he's
very hot right now
he played mbaku and once you actually
see Black Panther no spoilers happening
but once you actually see that you will
see how he is perfect for that
particular character with comedic timing
with actual breath as in breath is in he
got the chest space and it's important
for you yeah and then just for the
acting caliber it's really great for
beast man and then for man-at-arms I do
agree you need to have somebody that's
big Beasley has that you know comedic
time and everything and like I already
said this is not a Marvel property so
I'm gonna use him Bautista because he
would really Rock some man-at-arms and I
want to see him reach fat and he's kind
of already played man at all uh
man-at-arms so yeah gotcha UH one more
question just for my clarification of
your visions of your movie could you
compare the tone of your movie to an
existing film compare the tone of your
because you're both with your casts very
different I want to give me a taste of
the tone you want to give something the
fanboys the people that love he-man
because that's the reason you're making
him a movie to begin with his kids like
me into bought the action figures you
want to give them the movie that they
signed up for the movie they wanted with
the dolph lundgren one that they may not
have necessarily got keep the song
though so so you compare it to something
like Gardens galaxy sweeping space epic
but also weird also crazy because if
you've seen those toys there
so you want some of that weird crazy
energy you want some of that winking fun
but you also want that you know big
bombastic Conan the Barbarian epic much
less bloody 300 action in this movie so
that you can give give people it be a
movie experience they haven't had space
Conan before but it's something that
with Star Wars and Gardens galaxy and
all those there's those are movies that
still make money
gotcha Marky okay because yeah it sounds
like we're describing the same movie but
our movies are completely different my
space Conan is rock like that is you
know it's the Scorpion King fur for the
flavor of my movie it's Jumanji kind of
like Joe Johnson Jumanji with kind of
the Rhine s that you get with Joe
Johnston's Captain America the First
Avenger like kind with that where it's
got that gritty level to it but it's
also everybody has seen the Black
Panther trailer so you understand what
I'm saying with this but it also has
that ryan coogler character focus where
you have these badass people but you
also have that right comedy that goes in
there and you have that connection that
my movie is like he-man and Skeletor are
reflections of each other as in that
black mirror reflection because that's
something that we solve with this where
it's like you build up your hero great
but you have to have that villain that's
a reflection of that and reflection of
the hero and that is why Kevin Hart is
perfect time Wow different okay what a
battle and what very different duo's Dan
Merle hmm once you talk to us tell us
what you thought about this I just
couple things yeah technically he-man
would be Prince Adam his father King
Randor was the ruler of Eternia unless
there's a succession to the throne which
you never know people take things
I guess it's cuz rock is my king Jon M
Chu is a director who at one time way
back in 2013 was on board as the
director of Masters of the Universe and
he announced as his he-man channing
tatum who he had worked with previously
but he left that project back in 2013
and here we are almost 5 years later and
they just lost another director and
David s Goyer so fun times for Eternia
and I was very disappointed that no one
was cast as grill door but that's
because I I do love the Masters Universe
movie this was difficult for me overall
I didn't think there was one case that
was sold to me much stronger you seem to
agree more on your similarities a lot
than your differences so I had to go
with who who fought best for both of
their choices both he-man and Skeletor
and I felt like he both had pretty
strong cases for he-man but mark eeeh I
think made a much better case for her
Skeletor than DJ I didn't hear a lot
about Andy Serkis I heard a lot about
he-man but a lot about Skeletor and in
this case I'm gonna have to go through
maybe the better case for their pairing
and I'm gonna have to go with Mark eeeh
that's a great point Dan because when I
got like super jazz when I heard you
mention Andy Serkis
because I just saw Black Panther sorry
haters I saw and he was he's so good in
that and just the the masterful acting
that he brings to CGI characters I think
that could have been a huge tentpole of
your argument but yet Dan was Dan made a
great point and that you didn't sell
that enough and then but Marquis a-- you
you came at us with this like weird
funny tone and I wasn't quite sure about
it but then DJ cast both of your actors
in his movie he liked that stuff so much
so yeah I gotta go Marc eeeh yes
well I cast them in better rules so
marquise it takes this one Danielle tell
us what's going on Wow
so the Internet has said that they are
65 percent to 34 percent in favor of
Tatum circus against the rock have a
heart but we're not good we don't do
copter boat here people get me a couple
of notes that I saw I know you all
appreciate my love for bad movies but
you cannot keep telling me that you want
to cast Tommy Wiseau and everything and
everything we saw Terry Crews and
everything I also agree a lot of iCarly
guys don't forget if you want to get my
attention I also love corgis for
prestige casting y'all didn't call this
but I did we've got at J Peck 1098 who
says Dan Stevens is Heymann Kaman and
John Lithgow is collect or some other in
Merchant Ivory Masters of the Universe
another prestige casting Tom Hardy is
Heyman and Mads Mikkelsen as Skeletor
okay was by David Bowman 4-4-2 nice
Thank You Danielle
so mark here you took that point we are
all tied up quick question though is the
rock gonna wear that floppy hair bull
cut way he will at the beginning and
then it uh you know you know maybe it's
him in him and Skeletor go through high
school together okay round three what
the crap it's a blind fight alright
[Music]
alright you guys I got a hat oh no with
the things I thought you knew I thought
you were just telling us no oh I have no
idea what's going on as per usual okay
so I got a hat filled with things pick
one pick a thing pick a thing
things are good okay read us what is
your what your thing is
I got Deadpool Wolverine oh wow
here's the question well back to the now
you have your answers here's the
question which comic book character
should team up with Black Panther for a
movie which which comic book character
movie all right so you each have your
answer take a moment and think about it
that's more than enough DJ okay listen
Black Panther is a watershed moment in
cinema history people are raving about
it what was the last time people got
this amped as close to this amped in a
movie releasing in February Deadpool
thank you and and I think the poet would
add a lot to this movie because I'm sure
you know unfortunately I've seen it yet
I haven't seen Black Panther yet but I
you know I'm sure there's a lot of fun
entertaining cuber with it but Black
Panther is a more serious character and
you know when you have a community
character like Deadpool it is important
to have your straight man and so dipper
will be the perfect comedic foil for
Black Panther at a whole new different
dimension to the movie and also be
willing to make fun of some of the more
outlandish elements from the comic
select the magic dirt that gives him his
powers you know I mean like they all
these movies could afford to have the
piss taken out of them a little bit and
who better for that then Deadpool thank
you Mark eeeh Wolverine should be the
comic book character that teams up with
Deadpool sorry that teams up with a
black panther and I even have the comic
book property that they actually do it
in so they just couldn't do it
it's called doom war so in it
Black Panther has to okay so it has
Victor Von Doom as the main villain
Black Panther is
kind of ostracize out of Wakanda so you
remove him from his home base and Victor
Von Doom takes over Wakanda that him and
the debts Orry actually take it over so
he has to go for help and he goes to the
x-men for help and of them Wolverine is
the number one on board of we are going
to we're going to beat the evil wizard
he says we're gonna rescue the Queen
because storm is captured in Wakanda and
we're gonna save a country and he says
this into comic book panel while holding
a beer bottle cause it's Wolverine so
yeah it's called do more
long story short black panther cherie as
black panther at that point Wolverine
followed by the rest of the x-men then
do do take out all the doombots that
they're there but in the end black
panther ends up through advice from
wolverine he renders all the vibranium
and earth and that is the way that they
defeat do Wow impressive single panel
from a comic book recall alright guys
listen
Wolverine is a great character Black
Panther is a great character if you're
making a movie with them I think they're
too similar totally like you both do
characters whose primary and primary
weapons of choice typically in the in
the popular consciousness are claws
they're both kind of both can be kind of
broody you know there's not a lot of you
can create an interplay with it but the
dynamic between Deadpool and Black
Panther would be evident right from the
start when it'd be amazing the reason
why I don't think they should team up
for a movie is uh well not only do we
have Deadpool doing the whole thing with
cable and x-force right now I mean
that's gonna be that's and they already
signed up Josh Brolin with that for like
a I think it's like five films so
Deadpool won't be busy and he's good
he's busy and he's gonna be really big
while with this since we just came off
of Logan with everything this is a
really good time for recasting of
Wolverine so if you have a recasting of
Wolverine with Black Panther then you
have you have they're not gonna read a
screen for a black panther movie why not
be good but they wouldn't yeah you have
you'd have an Avengers vs. x-men movie
and and we already have Ryan Reynolds as
Deadpool
where do you have a shirt a MakerBot
Panthers may
and all the money you put those two
together you'd have an unstoppable
fighting force and also it'd be so much
you know when heroes get together they
always have to fight first before they
team up it'd be so much easier to get
those two fighting and be such a much
more dynamic and interesting fight Black
Panther would rip Deadpool to shreds and
it'd be hilarious
well I'm just saying for actual like
real-world circumstances type of a thing
like who out of those two characters
would be more likely Wolverine is the
one because because because I'm Logan is
done and buried because we have infinity
war which is very real likelihood that
it's that everybody dies movie and we
get a wipe with the reality Jim because
of that they then can yes recast the
Wolverine and they want that money
so having Wolverine team up together
with a huge property like Black Panther
not only does that whoever this actor is
not only does that catapult them up into
Wolverine status that gives us some more
Wolverine movies in a different tone
because he just paired up with black
pants we also but we're not talking
about real world scenarios cuz it's
gonna be at least three years until we
get we go we're not gonna get we're not
gonna get the x-men Avengers team-up for
at least another two to three years so
this is fun crazy what would make the
best movie and then what would make the
best movie is having Deadpool with Black
Panther the character dynamic is more
interesting it would bring the boats out
of both of the characters villain it was
a villain you would see them go up
against you would like to see them go up
against that's a great question yeah cuz
actually for me they're entirely too
dissimilar with the tones and like I
said they're they're just they're big on
their own it doesn't make sense to put
them together it does make sense for
Wolverine to be with Black Panther
another reason why it doesn't make sense
for Deadpool I mean besides the point
that he's going to be busy with all of
these other films with like cable shadow
star and so on and so forth is because
this already exists why are you gonna
reinvent the the wheel when you can just
put a rim on it when you're talking
about the comic that already has all the
X's you're getting some beat you're not
talking about a black if you talk about
that comic that's
are you saying is your movie gonna take
that same story that you described it
can take the same story but all you
would need is Wolverine you wouldn't
necessarily need the other x-men unless
by that point the sale had already gone
through and they wanted to put a couple
in but all you need really when you see
the fight all you need is Wolverine
shariah black you have a perfect villain
for this movie because you have you
could have weapon axe looking for
another alternative to adamantium for
creating their super soldiers and so
they try to get vibranium from black
panther Deadpool was part of the Weapon
X program as well and so you could have
them use a villain like cyber who
traditionally has adamantium arms maybe
you could have that be adamantium maybe
he's changing that for vibranium and
Deadpool and Black Panther team up to
take out Weapon X and so you have the -
it's like a buddy comedy you have the
two guys on a mission globe-trotting
around the world trying to end a weapon
axis clandestine program and like any
good body comedy they're getting on each
other's nerves their personalities are
completely different and through it they
learn to appreciate and not actually
like each other but appreciate each
other's differences and how they
complement each other and you could have
a buddy pairing two rival Lethal Weapon
you can make like 15 movies or isn't
that kind of a character that's not his
personality type at all and then also
why in the world with black panthers
specifically he is a very huge character
why in the world would he team up with
Deadpool to go take out a dementing when
he has vibranium at home it pulls there
anywhere Deadpool is a mercenary
Deadpool could have even and you can
have them hire Deadpool - she did it to
me first alright you can have them hire
Deadpool to take out Black Panther and
in the fight to pull realizes like hey
you're a good guy I don't need to do
this is your movie about Doctor Doom
taking over Wakanda yeah that would be
the main villain absolutely be Victor
Von Doom man those are both movies that
I would like to see so it really boiled
down to this organic pairing that would
come from what was inspired by the comic
versus this fun juxtaposition of
characters the crazy madman and the more
stoic king of Wakanda and who this is a
really difficult one because I would
love to see those movies I feel like we
haven't gotten a satisfying Doctor Doom
yet how do we live in a world where we
haven't gotten a good Doctor Doom was a
Toby Kebbell who play oh my god
yeah that's um that is that man you
really got me excited about that and
your like I bow down to your comic
book knowledge but then DJ was painting
the picture he I think you gave us an
interesting story about going to to get
the vibranium to for the Weapon X
program and why that pairing would work
and tonally you fit them together like
puzzle pieces I thought Deadpool and
Black Panther the way you sold it and
the one thing that I found that it was a
stumbling point for me and then you hit
on it DJ was you were talking about how
the movie would play in the real world
this is a movie fight it's like we like
we do crossovers there I feel like the
real world is much less of a factor and
when DJ called you out on that I felt
like he rebutted that nicely and for me
DJ gets the point Dan it's a tough one
yeah I bow down to that kind of
encyclopedic comic-book knowledge that I
will never possess but I think in
pitching the better movie I understand
the concerns with the conflicting
personalities but I also think that DJ
kind of smartly kind of wrapped his
argument around the fact like but that's
what makes their partnership interesting
and it just seemed like a more
compelling story to me and one that I'd
be more interested in you know an
adaptation of a Nolan story versus hey
let's take these two
just bounce them off of each other I
like how you tied in Weapon X to
vibranium and the comic book ties to
that and I'm gonna I'm gonna also go
with DJ alright DJ gets the point
Danielle what's going on on the world
wide web on the socials is so to start
off this pretty close this was the
closest they keep asking me if I'm sick
of new stuff how are you guys this was
the closest of all of the batches
according to the polls and right now
we've got Deadpool at 44% and Wolverine
at 55%
um a couple of the things that I noticed
so many of you were into just this nerd
versus nerd full-on comic book just
battle which is amazing a lot of you are
super ready for storm
mentioning because obviously a lot of
issues was Black Panthers kayfabe wife
for a minute hey the chat thank you
I have nice ones talking she has good
opinions just nice ones um a couple of
things I noticed on the Twitter yeah at
binging Netflix
I really hope Swamp Thing was a choice
in the Hat leak tag to Joestar
and at Road Raider 3 says oh man
DJ talks trash is in a good position
here I'd watch the hell out of a
Deadpool Black Panther movie would be
amazing and then one of the other ones I
saw was Black Panther and Deadpool vs.
MODOK come on DJ I can't tell you how
who's the other options were yes please
it was Batman uh-huh blade yeah the
other three options that were not select
Batman blade and Wonder Woman man I feel
like blade would have been a slam
for us picking characters out of a hat
and I hope you're ready to bring it to
the speed round speed round okay
okay so here's how it works it is
currently to one in favor of DJ we're
going to the speed round and the first
competitor to get four points for points
is gonna walk out of here a winner the
other one is going to have to ride the
bus to nowhere okay I'll see you there
so good company yes I know yeah I don't
even know what that means y'all okay
so first one to four points wins and
Danielle is going to still look at the
socials but she will be weighing in with
her own opinions as a judge now because
it's a speed round and so speedy there's
no time to compile that vote all right
are you all ready all right and again
you each get first person to speak
answers first and then you each get 20
seconds and then ten second rebuttals 10
second rebuttals okay so when you speak
you don't have to keep on speaking right
yes I we get both of your answers and
then the first person we heard will
elaborate on their answer first for 20
seconds okay great
here we go Cloverfield paradox dropped
last Sunday on Netflix what major movie
franchise should shift over to Netflix
only releases Resident Evil okay
heard fast and furious first so we have
fast and furious verse resident evil
DJ you have 20 seconds it'll begin
whenever you start talking what mean
closed field paradox blow up is ahead a
recognizable name fast fuse is one of
the most recognizable names in the world
and it's also winding up its main story
it's got one maybe two movies left two
officially left to wrap up its current
story you know they're gonna go next gen
with everybody's kids all those
characters have kids what a better way
to get people excited about those kids
that aren't Vin Diesel Paul Walker by
saying hey guess what we dropped it
today it's on Netflix time 20 seconds
Resident Evil has been it's a really
huge budget thing that has been steadily
getting worse and worse and worse but
people keep on watching it I think I'd
prefer to watch it and Netflix and the
you know safety of my own home kind of a
thing and Resident Evil is made for that
like Netflix TV movie type of property
10 seconds whenever you start Qatar
resting people is a fine franchise fast
and furious ISM is a franchise that has
gotten amazing and but it's facing
roadblock by having to reboot itself and
and that Netflix stunt got people about
Cloverfield is fast and furious is too
big of a movie to go into Netflix I mean
it keeps on getting bigger and bigger
each time and plus it's an event people
go to the theater together and bond
together and they have like watching
parties time Wow
alright Danielle Wow um I haven't had
time to look at your sick memes because
I was too busy looking at the facts
other parties in there oh my god oh you
got a lot of people were like hey
Danielle here are some other really good
ones and they're just corgis best um so
man I really like DJs arguments about
how fast and furious has a recognizable
name they need to wrap up the story
maybe they can go with the kids with
Marky for Resident Evil I do also agree
with the idea of like you want to watch
in the safety of her of your own home
but I really connected with your
rebuttal to the Fast and the Furious
movies and that Fast and Furious is too
big of a movie it is an event it is a
movie that people go to and they hang
out with their friends a lot of people
here I won't say any names rough are
very committed to the Fast and the
Furious and it is a movie that you see
in the theater and it's not a movie that
works on the small screen as you said
and so I'm going to for that I'm gonna
go with mer Kia that's one from our Kia
Dan yeah Marquis is well I agree with
Daniel there are bottles what did it
pointing out to the Fast and Furious
movies are getting more successful as
time goes along and also the argument
for the tone of Resident Evil the
dynamic being more befitting to the
Netflix type of mentality
Marc you got the point Marc he takes it
and FYI I agree for all those reasons
mentioned so we are locked up at two -
what a great moment in sports sports
question number two of the speed round
Paddington
director Paul King may remake Willy
Wonka yet again if he does who should
play Wonka who should play the new Wonka
Wonka Wonka 5 for Kevin Hart 3 Andy
Serkis now the foot is on the other hand
all right
we heard Kevin Hart first DJ your 20
seconds begins we have Kevin Hart vs.
Andy Serkis your 20 seconds begins when
you speak Willy Wonka's supposed to
create a fun sense of wonder by
simultaneously being somewhat
threatening Kevin Hart could capture
that fun exuberant energy while bring
something completely different to the
role he wouldn't be compared to gene
Wilder and also but he could create a
sense of unhinged maybe this guy should
be in charge of our tour even a little
time on the board for Kia Andy Serkis is
a phenomenal actor like a and he's great
with CGI he's great with fantastical
elements and everything like that and
the way that he is the way that he
structured in his acting he would fit
the Willy Wonka world perfectly and he
would kind of be a darker Wonka but a
fun Wonka
ten-second rebuttals we already had a
darker Walker with Johnny Depp and it
was too much and Andy Serkis would be
even scarier I don't know if he could
provide the fun that you would want from
the character that Kevin Hart could
easily do i Kevin Hart is not a leading
man he's a co-lead he'd actually be one
of the parents that said Willy Wonka
he wouldn't actually carry it by himself
why Andy Serkis can and by dark I meant
not like that time okay Kevin Hart worse
really versus Kevin Hart verse Willy
Kevin Hart where's Andy Serkis you know
what I feel like in your first and your
opening salvo you really summed up some
interesting reasons why Kevin Hart would
be a compelling Willy Wonka and I would
enjoy watching it making less of those
comparisons to the immortal iconic Gene
Wilder and yeah I don't feel like you
sold me enough on Circus and I think he
also knocked him down saying that that
would be a frightening currently in the
Chocolate Factory so I go with DJ
Danielle oh okay um so I again I did
appreciate his idea that Kevin Hart
would be fun exuberant energy unhinged
not have that comparison to Gene Wilder
I don't know where you get a threatening
Kevin Hart from haha that's literally
never gonna I don't know yeah he is a
very successful man but I can fit him in
my shoe um and I really enjoyed Mark
ia's idea like the end of circus he is a
great actor he is great with CGI he is a
dark and fun Wonka and for that I
thought that was really fun because that
is the idea and the thing that we loved
about Gene Wilder without getting to
Debbie as you mentioned and I agree
Kevin Hart he is no one's going to pay
him to be the leading man of a franchise
like I'm Wonka it's just not gonna
happen
he is a co-lead he can't carry it we
know that circus can because they let
that dude be monkeys so I am going to go
with more
yeah and I do want to put just one kind
of really fun thing that I got off the
so she's at Abram Levasseur put the only
one could we need and it is a gif of it
oh yeah okay
we're locked up at one one yeah I I
think people went back and forth it was
good back and forth but the one thing
that really resonated for me the most I
guess in the back and forth was the idea
that we've kind of gone with a different
take on Willy Wonka and that it didn't
work out so well and so I think that's
what went over for me and that was DJ so
I'm gonna go with DJ boom DJ gets the
point he is up three to two
mark Ian needs this point otherwise DJ
takes the day alright question number
three the speed round
DC is coming out with an anime called
ninja Batman what non ninja movie
character should get an animated film in
which they're a ninja ninja John what
you said ninja John wick yeah yeah
reading question DC is coming out with
an anime called ninja Batman what non
ninja movie character should get an
animated film in which they're a ninja
vixen vixen all right we have John wick
versus vixen DJ you spoke first time
begins when you speak John wick is a
film franchise built on its action and
it is tethered to human reality what
actual stuntmen can do imagine if you
could take that and completely
untethered from reality and do a
different take on the character with the
same a world of assassins ethos but
through anime action sequences that can
go even bigger even more over to stop
and really blow your mind
and new cool new ways are Kia vixen is a
DC character that she basically can
control animals for her to be a ninja
that would take her up to the next level
of she's african-american so having her
as a lead of a ninja team where there is
also animals involved you have animals
and ninja action and rooftops and that
would be amazing a perfect for animation
vixen already has an animated series and
nobody watches it so I think she's and
and John wick is a person that puts
butts in the seats because of the crazy
action if you told me I could get that
realistic world and also crazier one I'd
be in John wick is already kind of a
ninja so that's like a redundancy with
it you're just saying a John wick movie
as an animated thing and where was the
ninja thing vixen isn't a ninja and you
make her a ninja and then you have the
rooftops and then people watch it
because animated ninja animals oh wow
crazy stuff Dan Merle yeah you know
sometimes in these speed rounds that
play along in my head was not letting it
influence my judgment but Marcia Marcia
had the argument that I was playing in
my head which was is it John wick
already kind of a ninja and so that's
what pushed me over the edge plus the
idea and it's something else that I
think marki also made a better pitch for
why animation itself would be a better
venue for her choice so I'm Susan
Marquis got it Danielle yeah bummer um I
like DJ I love his arguments I do have
the idea of
just John wick fighting for dogs in
anime with does put butts in seats but
marki is right like he's already a ninja
it would just be animated John wick and
the appeal of done like it's kind of
also watching that dude just hit dudes
in the face I do like the idea of doing
something like that like ninjas and
animals on rooftops it does sound more
interesting and compelling and also I
did watch the Vixen series sir it's on
the sea she's a great character she's a
great character I'm sure for Halloween
once it was awesome all right so mark
iya takes it and John dude John wick
shoots a lot of dudes in the face as
well alright we're all locked up it
comes down to this
here it is Melissa McCarthy and Tiffany
Haddish are working on a crime drama the
kitchen what other usually comic actor
should make a crime film Oh
what other usually comic actor should
make a crime film 5/4
three
two and a half to one and a half won the
rock sea crow Steve Carell and the rock
hmm we heard the rock first mark eeeh
20 seconds begins whenever you speak yep
I'd like to take a moment thank
everybody for watching
[Music]
round round team okay okay I chose the
rock he should do a time splitters undo
that as a crime which is a it's like a
neo detective film where you have this
one character that has to travel through
time and actually solve mysteries
through time and the rock would be
perfect in that he's normally comedic
but it is a very gritty piece and he
would be able to read brought this out
of the park what you pitched was an
action movie based off of action game
starring an action star what makes a
good crime movies the intimate intense
conversations that people can have
around the threat of violence and Steve
Carrell while hilarious has proven
himself to be able to do those smaller
character beats like lost like flying he
did a very small intimate role he could
ain't he can be threatening like in
Foxcatcher
ten seconds begins whenever you talk
steve carell is just too comedic for me
to really just see him as a gritty crime
person while with the rock a gritty
crime means traveling through time he
can do that
see crawl is rocks bread and butter is
larger than life and again good crime
movies typically aren't larger than life
they're more they're more about human
interaction Steve crow nails that and
again he's proven time and again in
movies that he can not only be intense
but intimidating time Wow
Danielle this was difficult but as much
as I do appreciate like Marketo came
with the whole thing and I love
timesplitters and you came with an
entire you were like ready with like a
movie and a plot neo detective I want to
see both of these movies is the problem
they're just two different movies I do I
did appreciate DJ's argument about doing
a crime movie that was smaller the fact
that Steve Carell can do something more
intense like he didn't Foxcatcher was
probably the hinge for me so I'm gonna
go with DJ that's one Oh Dan yeah I
think that DJ had better counters and
also made a better case for my Carell is
capable of not just the the action part
but actually breaking down what the
elements of a crime film are the
grittiness the the fact that Steve
Carell has shown his ability to do this
in the past I think there's a big knock
down on Marquis 'singing picks an action
star and an action premise while I while
I notice that their gritty aspects of
the pitch I think DJ made a better case
for the crime element why Steve crow
would be better at it I'm going to DJ
Woolridge takes the day I would want to
rock time Spurs
i watch everything right on DJ
congratulations man awesomely done tell
us tell us where to find you
uh you can find me a DJ talks trash
every place that matters if you want to
hear me talk about my opinions on movies
every Monday morning you can check out
only stupid answers go to only stupid
answers calm for the podcast for the
videos for the merch everything you want
there hell yeah thank you sir and
Congrats welcome Bobby thank you also
well fought you really brought it you
know the last question mark iam Accardi
it was so great having you please tell
us something plug something uh yeah see
me on Marvel movie news that's that
popcorn talk that's Tuesdays at 2 p.m.
it is a live show and we are also a
podcast so please go ahead and listen on
iTunes and on Mondays at 9:00
I do WWE Raw after show yeah yeah so
that's after that's when afterbuzz TV
you guys ever talk blading no yeah okay
I need to let bleeding go I do before
you know what you'll like have bleeding
parties and everything yes I'm gonna
become a cutter of only my forehead
bleeding look it up Dan Moreau tell us
thank you mark eeeh yes awesome is so
much a good time Dan Moreau tell us
where to find you you're great
thank you sir
and Daniel Radford any final thoughts um
yeah you can just find me on Twitter I'm
very easy I got it first
sorry other video Radford's gang a gang
yeah and watch me and Mark eeeh we are
doing our spoiler review for Black
Panther that's coming out I believe on
Saturday morning on screen junkies og
original main whatever you want to call
it the first screen junkies nice that
very cool check it out
I want to thank Billy biz I want to
thank JT e I want to thank you all for
watching happy
Black Panther weekend bye-bye everybody
you